It’s such a beautiful day out here. The
air is alive with birdsong and the gentle
bubbling of nearby brooks. There are ancient
oaks everywhere, reaching up into the sky
and forming a dense canopy. The occasional
shaft of light spears through amongst the
leaves, illuminating the lush, green moss
on the ground below, as soft and perfect underfoot
as a brand new rug. This might seem like we’re
just having a pleasant jaunt through a local
forest here at SCP Explained, but take a closer
look at the trees.
This isn’t just any forest, dear viewers.
That’s right: After years of attempted espionage
and infiltration, we’re here at long last:
The Wanderer’s Library - The limitless,
interdimensional archive of all knowledge
in the multiverse, often frequented by the
Serpent’s Hand via portals known as The
Ways. Who would have guessed that the secret
to getting inside was just asking very politely
and promising not to steal any of the books?
We should try just being nice more often…
But hey, as the dispensers of user-friendly
animated knowledge here on YouTube, we felt
that we ought to share this bounty of limitless
knowledge with you. The wing of the Wanderer’s
Library we’re seeing right now is known
as the Hidden Nest, it’s a good starting
point for new scholars perusing the boundless
texts available beyond dimensions. How about
we begin with this collection over here: King
Shash’s Shelf. Try saying that three times
fast, and then take a look at the inscription
above the case:
“The lord of the lazy, his kingdom is anywhere
in which sloth reigns above activity, in the
hearts of all those devote to lounging over
labor. He and his secret army wage a war against
all do-ers, a battle for the universe that
can only end in the cessation of all motion
in the universe or total, unstoppable chaos.”
Lord of the Lazy, hm? Sounds like me when
I clock off for the weekend. Let’s crack
the spines on a few of these dusty old volumes
and take a look inside. First, we have “On
The Common Vampyre”, an extract from the
thought-to-be-lost Saint-Emile's Bestiary,
translated into English by the famed scholar
of the anomalous known as Rounderhouse. It
is an indispensable source of knowledge for
those who are aware of, and rightly fear,
the vampires that lurk in the dark all around
us.
It goes into great detail about the biology
of the Common Vampire - also known as Vampyrae
Draculae, and believed to be the progenitor
to all other vampire species - as well as
their diet, behavior, and the best methods
of hunting them. The following is a brief
extract.
“Vampyrae draculae is largely similar in
Shape and Forme to Homo sapiens sapiens - an
erect biped, with a wingspan roughly equivalent
to its height. The most obvious feature discerning
them from a Human is the shape of their hands
— the Vampyre's hands are claw-like, with
long, hard nails extending up to two centimetres,
often sharpened to a point. The muscles in
these hands are taut and powerful — they
can be quickly contracted to exert immense
pressure on anything in the Vampyre's grasp.
This ability is commonly used to crush the
skulls or bones of prey.
Naturally, the Vampyre's teeth are the second
source of notability. The Fangs of a Vampyre
are stuff of legend, and it is difficult to
extricate myth from fact. Dissection of the
adult Specimens have noted sexual dimorphism
in the dental region — while males have
two-score-and-eight teeth to the females'
two-score, they are less dangerous - four
of the males' can be described as Fangs, both
front-facing, two on top and two on bottom,
each a centimetre above the gumline. Comparatively,
females have eight Fangs, four in front and
two on each side. Her front Fangs are up to
one and a half centimetre above the gumline.
The legends have preserved one important bit
of truth regarding the Fangs; they are used
almost exclusively to suck Blood from the
Vampyre's prey. They bite into the flesh,
most often of the neck or thigh, and the Vampyre
uses its lips to create a seal around the
incisions before sucking. However, study of
their feeding habits has led me to an intriguing
discovery: as soon as the beast separates
itself from its prey, its Saliva soothes the
wound and encourages faster clotting. While
this is pure speculation, your author theorizes
that this is an Adaptation to preserve the
life of the prey in order to remain a consistent
food source.”
A truly fascinating piece of technical literature.
Next, of course, there is the short but haunting
piece titled “Leavings Of Another World”,
written by the great thinker Jack Manganese.
This tome carries an important lesson to all
who wander through the hallowed halls of the
Wanderer’s Library about the power of words.
But, it’s not the kind of power you might
think. Allow this extract to expand on that.
“Words have power.
Indeed, they have the power to create, but
mostly they have the power to destroy. Does
that really surprise you? Let me demonstrate.
Please think of an animal, any animal. It
could be anything, right? Two-legged? Four-legged?
Winged? Anything. But, now suppose I said
"Think of a quadruped". It can no longer be
two-legged, can it? It can no longer be a
bird or a fish.
And if I said, "Think of a black, domesticated
feline", your choices are narrower still.
And finally, "Think of Bastet, my pet black
cat"? At that point, you have no choices at
all. You may believe that each step gives
you more information, but what it really does
is limit your imagination and destroy possibilities.
The power to destroy, you see, is much greater
than the power to create. You just didn't
notice because you, yourself, are a creature
of thoughts, ideas, language, and ultimately
of words.
Suppose I told you there was once a world
without language, without ideas, without words.
Of course "world" itself is a word, so it
wasn't really a world, but we have to call
it something, now don't we?
In this world there were no limitations. Everything
that could be, was. Everything that couldn't
be, also was. It was a vast place of infinite
complexity, but also of infinite simplicity.
Since everything that was or wasn't, also
was or wasn't everything else, the endless
variety was in fact all the same. You say
it's difficult to describe? Indeed, that's
the point: It can't be described. It was everything
and anything, and something and nothing, and
all-at-once and not-at-all.
What happened to it? Words, of course. It
started with a single, simple word, in a language
that no one speaks anymore. No one knows where
it came from or how it sounded, but I'll tell
you what it meant. It meant "red", and as
soon as there was "red" there was also "not-red".
The world had been neatly cloven into red
any-every-somethings and not-red any-every-somethings.
It was the first division, and the very idea
of division spawned more ideas and more words:
"one", "two", "separate", "together", "us",
"them", and from these came more: many, many
more.”
The piece then goes on to reveal that the
proliferation of language destroyed this world
further, until all that was left was the wreckage:
Our world. How a universe of infinite possibilities
is slowly dulled by the ever-expanding power
of nomenclature. Truly a disturbing thought
for the more metaphysical among you.
Let’s take a look at another book from King
Shash’s collection. Next comes a frightening
parable about hubris from The Bard, known
as “Jack of Trades.” Like many a classic
parable, this piece tells the tale of an intelligent
spider - a Jack of Trades, as the story puts
it - whose arrogance forges him into the architect
of his own demise. Let’s take a look at
an extract, shall we?
“I once met a spider named Jack. A sizeable
fellow he was, the size of my fist, and eight
legs as long as my hand. They were dexterous
too, complementing his keen mind. That was
where his name came from—Jack of Trades,
for with each leg he would conduct each of
his trades.
With one he was a blacksmith, forging steel-like
silk that with another he would spin into
death traps. With a third he would contemplate
the design of his web, for he was an architect.
With the fourth he would climb the tallest
of trees and bask in the daylight so that
all would see his splendour, and in it take
delight.
Oh yes, he was proud. Why wouldn’t he be?
He was the most talented spider to have ever
graced the land, his crafts as numerous as
they were grand.
“I don’t just weave webs,” He said to
me, “I weave works of art, my traps instruments
of death so much finer than all the rest.”
Then one day, Jack hatched a plan. Up the
tallest of trees he climbed. He did not rest
for two nights and two days, until he reached
the highest branch. The words some proclaim
say he could touch the moon up there, but
I digress, for one thing was certain; the
height he had reached was a thing to impress.
What Jack did next was more august still.
Working each of his renowned legs he weaved
a web from the base of the branch to its end.
So mighty in scale was it that he said it
would catch him the sun, and make him master
of all that it touched.
“It will bring me the moon too,” He told
me once, “and with the light of the brightest
star I shall be master of the night.”
Catch them he did, for as the sun climbed
it found itself twined in the mesh of Jack’s
web. As for the moon, it soon found itself
strewn with Jack's string, which clung to
its opalescent veneer as it drew near to its
ever-evasive lover, the bringer of day. Now
they were tied to one another in Jack's trap
for him to reign over! It was thus he crafted
himself a throne of sunlight and moonlight,
the very heavens made to bow before his majesty.
Yet it was not to last.”
The rest of the tale details the downfall
of Jack the Spider, as he devours the sun
and the moon above, driven by his boundless
hunger for greatness. Soon enough, he was
left with nothing to consume, and in his despair,
tumbled from his web down to his doom. So
is often the way with those pushed by unchecked
ambition.
Time to blow the dust off another one of the
Library’s forbidden tests. This one, entitled
“A Restless Wanderer On The Earth”, is
a particularly interesting piece for anyone
fascinated by the enigmatic life of SCP-073,
also known as Cain. This piece features a
person named Bluebird buying a jar containing
Cain’s memories from a merchant - possibly
affiliated with Marshall, Carter & Dark Ltd.
It’s a complex tale concerning many small
fragments from Cain’s life, thousands of
years in the past. Here is a brief excerpt:
“The man found Cain ben Adam in the endless
wildernesses of the between-places. The man
was beautiful to look upon, with bronzed skin
and shaggy black hair. His clothing was cut
of animal skin, of fashions pleasing to the
eye. But Cain was not pleased to see him.
The man knew his name.
"I am a priest," the man said. "A year ago,
you passed through my village. I wished to
follow you then, but I was held back by the
others. Then the crop failed, and a plague
swept through our village. Only I was able
to save myself, and then, there were none
to hold me back. I have searched for you since,
and now I have finally found you."
Cain frowned. He tried to wander only those
lands where the soil was wild and suffused
with power enough to resist his curse, or
else lands where the inhabitants knew how
to refresh the lands which his curse had made
barren.
When he needed to pass through civilization,
he avoided the fields. He had long ago discovered
that his curse had a limit — forty-eight
cubits around him, or a length similar to
twelve times his own height. Enough to judge
with the naked eye.
But that did not account for the times he
was not fully aware. Often, taken with wanderlust,
sometimes not even fully awake, he would walk
in a trance according to where his feet took
him alone. After these periods, he could awake
having destroyed the entire harvest for a
village.
"I am truly sorry," Cain said.
The man looked astonished. "You are Cain,
the Wanderer, father of the Lost Children
and the Great Beasts. You are the god of death.
The other gods, the lesser gods, could not
save my village. I worshiped them once. I
despise them, now. I come now to worship you."
"They were your family," Cain said. "Even
if they were not, I cannot be pleased about
bringing more death to those who did not deserve
it."
"You are testing me, my lord." The man's teeth
gleamed. "I promise you, I will not disappoint
you. I will become your follower, and your
priest!"
"Foolish," Cain said, and continued walking.
The man followed him.”
It’s clear that the curse Cain is forced
to carry, since committing the terrible sin
of murder against his own brother, weighs
heavily upon him. And the powers he possesses
now are both a blessing and a terrible detriment
to the normal life he would have led. As with
anything involving Cain, it’s a deeply tragic
tale.
Next comes another insight into a normally
secretive world. A piece entitled “The Exhibition”,
written by an aspiring Anartist named Artifex.
The piece details his frustrating experience
hosting his artwork at a private exhibition
hosted by the sinister members of Marshall,
Carter, & Dark Ltd. And of course, here is
a brief extract.
“I had never been so disappointed before.
Tonight was supposed to be my big night, the
anart exhibition that would define my career.
Hosted by the richest men of the anomalous
world, Marshall, Carter & Dark, luminaries
from all across the multiverse had come to
see our work.
I remembered how surprised and excited I was
to see the letter that I had even been accepted
into the exhibition. To receive one of these
had been my dream since I was a child, learning
all about the wonders of the anomalous on
my father's knee. The letter looked so formal,
with the logo of MC&D printed at the bottom,
that I thought it sealed my future forever.
I spent five hours fretting beforehand. I
eventually settled on a suit to wear, a black-and-white
chessboard pattern, only with actual chess
pieces that moved and played games over the
fabric. I had specifically requested that
it be made with some of the most famous games
of history sewn into it, but when I looked
down at myself, I could not tell which game
was which. Before I could second-guess my
choice of clothing, I looked at the time,
and realised that I was running slightly late,
and left in a hurry, rushing to the portal
that the letter told me to go, in between
a bookshop and a bowling alley.
When I arrived, my astonishment at seeing
the place was a feeling I would never forget.
It was ridiculously surreal, like if M. C.
Escher painted an art museum, and the museum
was filled with Escher's paintings, with the
paintings themselves being alive. The chandeliers
were made from glowing crystals, almost looking
more like disco balls than chandeliers. The
crowd there was as impressive as the art,
with all sorts of people from all sorts of
dimensions, dressed in the finest suits, capes
and cloaks that money could buy. As I approached
the host, a tall, imposing figure, with grey
robes, a metal mask and a mane of white hair,
I felt very intimidated.
'Yes, yes, I've been awaiting your arrival,
Natura,' he was saying to a woman before him,
a human with a green dress–that I quickly
noticed was actually made out of leaves–and
dark green hair to match, flowing down past
her shoulders, with flowers in her hair and
clothes. 'Your work is waiting for you in
the west wing.'
The woman, who I assumed was named Natura,
eagerly nodded and looked over to her right.
She started walking so quickly, she almost
bumped into me…”
The night didn’t go much better for Artifex
after that. His anart pieces were a painting
of a woman who makes you fall in love, a vase
that kills anything put inside it, and a little
statue of an archer who fires real arrows.
The representatives of Marshall, Carter, & Dark
were not impressed by this meager display,
leaving Artifex - who’d mainly gotten in
from his father’s business connections - feeling,
we’ll say, less than stoked.
But the Wanderer’s Library isn’t all just
technical documents and prose. There’s also
a fair share of spellbinding poetry in these
dusty old pages. Take, for example, “Stars
wait for no man” by the illustrious poet
who goes only by Doctor Pann. It’s a powerful
and melancholy piece, presented here, in full.
“The Abyss is an infinitude,
Unknown and unknowable.
Creatures with mouths over throats
Seek insight into their existence,
Gazing at that which only gazes back.
They choke as they look,
Windpipes bent awkwardly,
Tears trickling from their eyes.
Windows reflecting
A goal, unachievable.
Eyes peer into darkness
Searching for more and more,
Yearning, hoping, desiring.
But not doing, never going,
Weeping at the beauty beyond reach.
A number tried
Reaching out to the void,
But the others scoffed,
Drowning the doers with tears.
All While they rested,
Their asses in the dirt.
An eternity separates
That which seeks
And that which is sought.
Eternity only grows as they gaze on,
Dreaming, but not doing.
Stars wait for no man.”
The Wanderer’s Library is a truly fascinating
place, with so much strange beauty and arcane
knowledge to gather up and learn. Would you
like us to cover more of the many esoteric
volumes in the Library’s infinite shelves?
Let us know down in the comments. And we thoroughly
recommend you check out all the full tales
in the Library itself, using the link in the
description.
Just be careful when you do so. It’s easy
to get lost in there…
Now go check out “SCP-6000 - The Serpent,
the Moose and the Wanderer's Library” and
“SCP Serpent's Hand Explained” for more
on the legendary library between dimensions!